78 89 ans je me souvenais cuisine
numérotée 11 février 2005 pour la
première fois depuis trente ans je
reviens avec ma soeur michelle dans la
maison je suis né
bonjour monsieur on habitait là
les nouveaux locataires sont sourds et
muets mais j'arrive tout de même à me
faire comprendre
la dernière fois que ma soeur et moi
avons franchi ce portail c'était le 13
septembre 1973 juste deux jours après le
putsch militaire qui a renversé le
président allende et qui a bouleversé
notre vie à jamais
c'était ta chambre ma chambre ça c'était
ta chambre tu avais une chambre portant
de celles achetées garçons
ça c'est l'argent de papa maman il y
avait un grand lit là il y avait une
commode ici et ici c'est dans cette
chambre la moins
vrai c'est dans cette chambre
basse et leurs champs c'est comme si
tonton shanghai - si ce projet
se voir ils étaient là comme ça parce
que je me rappelle mes mois-ci là et
j'ai et je voyais pas pas dans la salle
de
gym après il était assis là dans les
toilettes
sur les toilettes mais les militaires
restent et où c'était partout où ils
étaient partout mais maman l'était au à
l'état vêtu de noir
papa était assis là
et il avait un mec qui si j'ai un autre
couac à notre vide à cela
parce qu en fait voilà c'est comme ça
que c'était ils ont commencé à nous
taper et après ils l'ont amenée ici
et là il en glace a été vraiment super
violent
super super
gt speed
c'était super
j'étais assis là même a dit ça va aller
portail
web
houle
ça remue les souvenirs
c'est dingue
je m'appelle y baraibar comme mon père
une tradition au chili pour le premier
garçon de la famille le seul parmi cinq
filles un privilège lourd à porter aussi
lorsqu'on a six ans et que l'on voit son
père se faire torturer devant ses yeux
mon père est chilien et ma mère est
française ils se sont connus à saint
germain des prés en 1960 un coup de
foudre un départ précipité pour le chili
et six enfants de l'amour qui vont
suivre
mon père c'est lui à l'époque du bonheur
il est rédacteur en chef du journal le
plus proche d'ayem d
c'est lui qui m'a inoculé le virus du
journalisme
du coup d'état contre le président
allende de la prise du pouvoir par le
général pinochet
l'histoire retiendra près de 3000 morts
en quelques semaines
moi à part ce jour où j'ai cru ne plus
revoir mon père et ma mère j'ai perdu la
plupart de mes souvenirs
j'ai toujours su que quelque chose de
terrible ray est arrivé lorsque les
militaires les ont emmenés mais mon père
a toujours refusé de m'en parler
ibars akbar et mort à paris le 6 juin
2004 ce retour au chili après trente ans
d'absence c'est pour lui que je les
entreprises pour lui pour sa soif de
vérité et de justice
tia mercedes notre voisine de l'époque
c'est elle qui nous a sauvés mais ce
rémois sans son intervention les
militaires nous auraient embarqué avec
mon père et ma mère elle habite toujours
à côté il ya par ses cheveux blancs elle
n'a pas changé
au moment où ils les ont emmenés ton
père était dans un sale état
il saigne est partout même des oreilles
comme il ne traînait par terre j'ai cru
qu'il l'avait tué moi aussi je les crues
j'étais terrorisée
puis mercedes va nous révéler à ma soeur
est à moi un souvenir que nous avions
totalement occulté
après le départ de vos parents un
gendarme est entré chez nous pour
demander où était sergio mon mari le
gendarme est entré dans cette chambre où
vous étiez tous les six et là vous étiez
tous regroupés au fond de la pièce avec
mon mari juste derrière où
vous étiez assis sur lui comme
instinctivement vous saviez qu'il
fallait le cacher aux yeux des
militaires quand j'ai vu la sienne j'ai
répondu il n'est pas là et ça a marché
mais je n'avais que l'epr c'est que
l'inde lui vende la mèche
finalement nous si nous avions sauvé
quelqu'un malgré notre peur
tu sais on n'arrivait pas à dormir la
nuit
on entendait tirer tout le temps si tu
es tellement le monde les hélicos pas
c'est toute la nuit toute la nuit on
entendait tirer depuis les hélicos
je crois que cela a duré avec cette
intensité pendant deux mois
je ne pensais pas qu'on pouvait se
souvenir de tout ça
deux mois de répression terrible où les
arrestations arbitraires les exécutions
sommaires et la torture atteindront leur
paroxysme
parce qu'elle est française ma mère va
être libérée après nous avoir mis à
l'abri dans le nord du pays elle va
rester à santiago réfugié à l'ambassade
de france où elle va tenter d'obtenir la
libération de mon père je vais rester
sans nouvelles d'eux pendant deux mois
première étape de mon enquête le siège
de la codp époux une association qui
regroupe des avocats pour la défense des
victimes de la dictature
c'est la mémoire vivante des années de
plomb au chili
bye bye bye bye
bye bye à mais je connais très bien ta
carte enfin je veux dire celui de ton
père je m'en suis occupé personnellement
ce sont des dossiers que l'on a pris
très à coeur d'ailleurs dans le livre on
a publié la déclaration de ton papa
quand mon père a déposé un dossier ici
un témoignage envoyée depuis paris en
1998 le numéro 5 137 sur la liste des
28000 personnes reconnues comme victimes
de la torture
je connaissais l'existence de ce
témoignage mais je ne l'avais jamais lu
en tout une quarantaine de lignes
presque rien sur les tortures qu'il a
subies et à ma grande déception aucun
nom aucune piste qui pourrait mener aux
responsables de notre malheur
mais il donne aucun détail mon père
qui ne désigne personne mais c'était
pour vous éviter des souffrances à vous
les enfants à votre mère s'il n'a pas
donné de détails
en fait je ne sais pas mais ça reste un
document historique drôme à ton père a
comparé où il est passé tu vois là et
puis là
mais comment c'est possible mon père
était journaliste il savait écrire
pourquoi il ya si peu de détails je ne
sais pas je ne sais vraiment pas mon
père n'est pas le seul à ne pas pouvoir
raconter sa torture
c'est le cas pour la plupart des gens
qui ont témoigné dans ce livre
[Musique]
après son arrestation mon père va passer
deux mois au stade national le stade de
football de santiago du chili transformé
en un gigantesque camp de torture par la
junte militaire
plus de quarante mille prisonniers
hommes et femmes
cette photo d'une femme qui parle à son
mari emprisonné a fait le tour du monde
à l'époque c'est celle de mon père et de
ma mère
pour en savoir plus sur ce qui s'est
passé pendant ces deux mois j'ai donné
rendez-vous à cet homme alberto gamboa
c'était le directeur du journal ou
travailler mon père
oui c'est bien par là qu'ils m'ont fait
passer
alberto a été arrêté quelques jours
après mon père il a accepté de revenir
avec moi sur les lieux de leur cauchemar
dans les couloirs du marché au milieu de
gens étendue à plat avant il y en avait
partout ne pense pas qu'il y en avait
trois ou quatre s'est établi sept corps
alors il fallait marcher comme ça pour
les éviter enfin moi en tout cas je
marchais comme ça les militaires eux les
petits nés comme si c'était des bêtes
entre minuit et une heure du matin
ils ont fini par me trouver un endroit
où dormir
c'était un vestiaire
je sais pas exactement si c'était celui
là mais pareil à investir comme ça
à l'époque qui les détenus dorment et à
6-2
6-2 4-6
il y avait six types six personnes que
des sommes
là dans la première douche j'ai retrouvé
une barre akbar bien assis sur sa
couverture
deux personnes tiennent dans chaque
douche assieds toi pour voir
je vais me mettre à côté de toi
qui te voilà on y est
il va arrêter là avec son pater est
désormais comme ça et comment je suis
passé quand vous vous êtes retrouvé
une énorme accolade oms est tombé dans
les bras et on a versé quelques larmes
je croyais qu'il était mort et lieu
aussi me croyez mort
on sait raconter nos arrestation celle
de ton père a vraiment été terrible il
m'a dit que les soldats n'avaient fait
aucune différence entre ton père un
homme qui pouvait résister plus qu'amer
qui est une femme c'était une
arrestation vraiment très violente
comment était mon père physiquement
très maigre vraiment très maigre
mais il faut que tu saches que le régime
était très dur
je t'ai dit que l'on dormait dans les
vestiaires et en fait on passait toute
la journée dans les vestiaires ils
baissent plus de 80 personnes ici
il y avait des gens qui dormait assis
il fallait tirer les jambes à tour de
rôle sauf ton père qui avait plus de
place ici c'est pour cela je crois qu'il
tenait autant cette douche
alberto va me mener dans un endroit dont
je n'avais jamais entendu parler un
petit bâtiment un peu à l'écart du stade
c'est là que se dérouler les séances de
torture avant de rentrer les soldats
bandé les yeux des prisonniers
alors ici je vais te montrer
on nous alignés le long de ce mur
et on rentrait un par un au fur et à
mesure qu il nous appelait
ici les interrogatoires étaient plus
raffinés ou plus scientifique comme il
disait
enfin si on peut utiliser ce terme pour
qualifier leur brutalité
ont attaché les mains sur le sony en fer
et les jambes aussi et l'opéra us
et là on te bat r on appliquait du
courant sur les testicules sur les
mamelons
et qu'est ce qu'ils te demandent est ce
que tu faisais moi j'étais directeur du
journal alors me demandait à qui
appartient le journal à qui tu l'a vendu
qu'il a vendu allende à lady noctule a
vendu allende et à mon père on lui
demandait les mêmes choses ah oui bien
sûr qu'on c'était le tour de ton père et
lui demander les mêmes choses
nous on n'a jamais vu le visage des
tortionnaires
jamais jamais
avant de mourir mon père a écrit un
livre où il raconte une anecdote sur le
stade national celle d'un policier qui
va braver ses supérieurs pour lui venir
en aide
ce policier je les retrouver c'est
l'huître one je vais lui lire ce que mon
père a écrit sur lui
l'homme a roué de coups avec ses pieds
et ses mains comme s'il voulait montrer
sa détermination face aux militaires qui
nous entoure est il s'est arrêté à bout
de souffle quand je gisait par terre et
il s'est approché de moi elle m'a dit à
l'oreille
désolé camarades pour ses coûts et
j'étais obligé pour ne pas éveiller la
méfiance des militaires qui nous entoure
votre femme michelle a été libéré du
stade et elle s'est réfugiée à
l'ambassade de france evo 6 enfants sont
dans votre famille le nom
pardonne moi pour les coûts mais il faut
que je donne le change sinon on va y
passer tous les deux
mais si j'ai voulu rencontrer quan c'est
surtout dans l'espoir qu'il m'aide à
retrouver ceux qui ont vraiment
d'ordures et mon père
riba reiba ton papa
à je n'avais jamais vu cette photo
la dédicace et deux mois à kuan l'homme
qui m'a permis de connaître mon père
même après le 11 septembre 73
c'était normal de réagir comme ça quand
on voyait les conditions dans lesquelles
étaient les gens là bas c'était la
moindre des choses
laisse moi m'en remettre
il faut qu'on s'embrasse
kiwan
c'est toi on va pouvoir discuter
maintenant
alors qu'ils s'occupaient des
prisonniers politiques il avait une
équipe spéciale qui s'appelait le
service d'intelligence de l'armée le
cimt après ils ont changé son nom
c'était la direction de l'intelligence
militaire le dinh
alors toi tu ne sais pas quelles étaient
les bataillons qui ont travaillé dans le
stade on sait qu'on est qu'ils
appartenaient à l'armée de l'air à
l'armée de terre ou aux marines
il y avait des gens de l'armée de l'air
des gens de l'armée de terre et des
gendarmes les carabiniers mais je n'ai
jamais vu des gars de la marine jamais
mais tu sais c'était difficile de savoir
qui était qui ils portaient tous des
uniformes identique sans aucune
décoration sans aucun drame
là encore pas un seul nom comme mon père
one reste très vague pour lui aussi
vingt-cinq ans après le traumatisme est
toujours là nous une personne n'a
protesté
personne n'a dit stop
l'armée vous donnez l'impression d'être
tellement fort tellement intouchable
c'était fou vraiment personne n'a osé
intervenir en faveur des prisonniers je
te parle de la période 73 à 76 personne
ne sait de l'intéressé alors ça pendant
trois ans les services de sécurité ont
pu faire leur travail de répression en
tout lien
je décide d'aller dans le nord at
chacabuco à plus de 1600 km de santiago
c'est là que mon père a été transféré
après ces deux mois passés au stade
national c'est un camp de prisonniers en
plein milieu du désert
avec moi ma mère la femme qui porte un
chapeau et la plupart de ma famille
c'est la première fois depuis 25 ans que
nous nous retrouvons tous réunis au
chili
l'homme qui conduit c'est roberto mon
oncle il connaît l'endroit il y était
venu avec mon père il y a dix ans
[Musique]
tout de suite nous sommes saisis par le
silence qui règne ici
le camp a été transformée en musée par
le nouveau gouvernement chilien qui l'a
dédié aux victimes de la dictature
mon père est né dans cette région son
enfance il l'a passé à quelques
kilomètres de cette ancienne mine de
salpêtre où on l'a mis en prison le
gardien comme mon père est aussi un
ancien prisonnier politique
il vivait à combien dans ce baraquement
9 par pièce il y avait trois fois trois
lits superposés
alors par bharathi cement ils étaient 18
oui dans chaque bar attenant il y avait
neuf +9 donc ça fait dix-huit
il y avait en tout 1000 100 prisonniers
voilà
la maison
et me disais justement été ouverte il
était initié alpin quand il est arrivé
après lésion
le pape a cherché partout un peu de mal
à retrouver
mais la maison c'est celle là
et comment se sentait pas pas quand il
est revenu ici
il était tellement ému
il voulait rester seul
imaginez un peu c'est seulement à ce
moment-là que ses souvenirs ont commencé
revenaient
avant de partir pour le chili j'avais
retrouvé ce film sur les conditions de
vie dans le camp des prisonniers de
chacabuco
ce sont les seules images dont je
dispose
elles ont été tournées sous haute
surveillance par des journalistes
est-allemand en 1974
et parmi le millier de prisonniers du
camp un homme va être interviewé plus
longuement que les autres et cet homme
c'est mon père
j'ai été arrêté chez moi le 13 septembre
dans la nuit les motifs de ma détention
je ne les connais toujours pas pour le
moment il n'y a aucun élément à charge
contre moi
pendant ces cinq mois de détention at
chacabuco mon père n'a eu droit qu'à une
seule visite
ça c'est le théâtre tu vois c'est ici
qu'a eu lieu la visite celle de sa soeur
ma tante je me rappelle que quand on
rentrait il y avait des barbelés là bas
les prisonniers étaient entassés
derrière loin tout là bas
comment était-il moralement à ce moment
là il s'est toujours montrée entier
devant moi
il n'a jamais craqué
c'est même lui qui me remonter le moral
c'est lui qui nous consoler il disait
qu'il allait bien et qu'il ne fallait
pas ce qu'il dit
qu'est ce que tu ressens ici maintenant
de la peine
beaucoup de peine
de l'impuissance
qu'il a dû traverser tout cela sans
raison
parce que je le dis toujours si tu as
commis un crime tu doit le payer
mais si tu n'as rien fait pourquoi tu
dois passer par là
ma mère est restée à l'écart pendant
toute la visite du camp seule perdue
dans ses pensées à relire le livre de
mon père avant de partir elle a demandé
à voir le gardien du musée de chacabuco
loin de ma caméra ellle offert un
exemplaire du livre sans doute une
promesse faite à mon père avant qu'il ne
décède mon père qui même prisonnier est
resté journalistes avec d'autres détenus
il a créé ce journal le journal du camp
parce qu'il faut toujours se surpasser
face à l'adversité comme il aimait à le
dire c'est la première fois que ma femme
ils découvrent ces images moi j'étais
rédacteur en chef du quotidien clarin
quand j'étais arrivé on a décidé de
créer un journal ici dans le camp pour
stimuler la créativité qui s'est
développée parmi nous et aussi pour
remonter le moral des camarades pour que
notre séjour ici soit moins pénible
tout cela nous aide à surmonter les
traumatismes provoqués par ce genre de
détention
si l'on n'enseigne pas aux jeunes ce qui
s'est passé pas nécessairement pour
désigner les coupables alors tout peut
recommencer à l'identique d'ici 15 20 30
en
l'église demandent que l'on pardonne
moi non
pas de pardon
et la drire j'espère vivre assez vieux
pour les voir tous en prison
c'est ça que
je décide de rentrer à santiago et de
poursuivre mon enquête
je ne sais toujours pas qui est torturé
mon père au stade national et plus les
jours passent plus j'ai l'impression que
je ne le saurai jamais
en désespoir de cause je décide de
demander de l'aide à une personne que
mon père admiré c'est le juge guzmán le
tombeur général pinochet
après sept ans de procédure acharné il a
réussi inculpé l'ancien dictateur prix
pour crimes contre l'humanité
pourtant s'il accepte de me recevoir il
n'est pas très optimiste trouvez les
laits les tortionnaires qui ont des
tortures et tellement des gens 28000
personnes non plus je pense que ça va
être une tâche très très difficile
peut-être on peut trouver quelques-uns
mais je pense que la plupart vont rester
dans les impunités
comment arriver à faire condamner les
tortionnaires de mon père
sans le vouloir le juge guzmán va
finalement me mettre sur la voie en me
faisant raconter une nouvelle fois ma
propre histoire
celle d'un enfant qui le 13 septembre
1973 à l'âge de 6 ans a été forcé de
regarder son père se faire torturer
devant ses yeux
le juge gossmann va me la prendre
aujourd'hui la loi chilienne considère
cela comme un crime si vous avez
quelqu'un
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de crimes
contre l'humanité la torture est un
crime contre l'humanité alors
parfaitement vous pourrez faire
l'accusation vous pouvez
présenter une plainte contre cette
personne est elle à la justice a
l'obligation de de faire l'enquêté et
naturellement de si cette personne est
trouvé coupable de cette personne doit
être condamné vous pouvez le faire et
même même plus je pense que vous devez
le faire
non et ce n'est pas une vengeance et
c'est c'est ce que doit faire tout
personne toute personne qui qui a qui
connaît de l'existence d'un délit ou un
crime et qui c'est qui est la personne
qui a connu qu commis non
excusez moi d'être six fois mais je
pense que c'est une obligation naturelle
mais c'est pas de la vengeance
brusquement je réalise que parmi les
personnes qui m'ont forcé à regarder mon
père se faire torturer il y en a au
moins une que je peux espérer retrouver
c'est le voisin qui l'a dénoncé
d'après le juge d'ousmane il est aussi
coupable que les autres
ce voisin on le surnommait ciccio titcho
a listé
je décide aussitôt de retourner une
nouvelle fois enquêter dans mon quartier
et vous connaissez situe à lyster
l'habitait ici
oui c'est vrai qu'il est du quartier
mais il n'a jamais habité cette maison
et vous savez dans quelle maison ils
habitent
il s'appelle bien titcho a listé non
pourquoi vous demandez tout ça parce que
j'habite est ici quand j'étais petit je
suis fils de michel et iba 7 fils de la
michel
ah je vois où tu veux en venir viens par
là
il cherche après le diable
toi tu cherches après là
je cherche la personne qui a dénoncé mon
père
oui mais tu ne peux pas me demander
comme ça de but en blanc
je sais qui est cette personne le [ __ ]
mais aujourd'hui il a les jambes
amputées il est en fauteuil roulant
l'enfoiré
je me souviens bien de michel avec tous
ses enfants quand elle a dû s'exiler à
l'ambassade pour partir avec tous ces
enfants en france
moi je suis le petit ben regarde j'en ai
la chair de poule
embrassez moi
ça me retourne mon chéri ils ont
tellement souffert ces petits moineaux
enfin roues les enfants
l'épicière madame saint-yves agnès
décide de m'aider en fait tout le monde
connaît la personne que je cherche dans
mon quartier et je vais même apercevoir
que tout le monde se rappelle aussi de
notre histoire
regarde qui je t'amène le fils de michel
la française non mais si
tu es le fils tu ailles barre mais ces
petits bars je ne te crois pas nommé
film papier tu vois tu vas entre donc
pas
à lister était une balance il a aussi
dénoncé une autre voisine marc sakal
barral qui habitait en face
les gens veulent que ces criminels
regrette ce qu'ils ont fait mais il y en
a aucun qui a demandé pardon
il a dit ça me met tellement en colère
de les voir dans les églises
quand tu vois que pino chez à une
chapelle privée alors tu te dis
comment ils peuvent prier
ils n'ont donc aucun romand pour ce
qu'ils ont fait et comment l'église les
laisse comme signé alors que l'église
interdit la communion des divorcés
comment l'église peut permettre à des
assassins de participer à l'eucharistie
tu comprends ce sont les éternels
contradictions de ce pays et elles vont
continuer car au chili on a perdu la
mémoire est ici une personne ne parle de
ces choses là ni dans les écoles ni
ailleurs je te comprends mais pour le
moment ma chère ritualiste est
oui alors à lister
sa fille habite paris 6 mai lui
apparemment il est dans un fauteuil
roulant et vit maintenant dans un autre
quartier
s'écroule qu'est qu'il à m'aider à
retrouver le nom et l'adresse complète
de l'homme qui a dénoncé mon père
alors c'est quoi son nom voilà mario
liste héros salle c'est ça son nom
complet est un nom une adresse c'est
suffisant au chili pour déposer plainte
alors je retourne voir les avocats qui
aide les victimes de la dictature et
tout d'un coup comme si un verrou avait
sauté je me souviens précisément du
comportement de mario à lister ce soir
là
tu dis qu'ils appartenaient à la milice
mais ça ne veut rien dire tu sais ce qui
se passe habituellement c'est que le
gars dénoncer et dès que les carabiniers
arrivés sur place et à rentrer chez lui
oui mais lui il est resté tout le temps
comme si diriger l'arrestation c'est lui
qui commandait oui en quelque sorte y
avait bien des officiers sagement appel
mais c'était lui qui les incitaient à
battre mon père il est resté des heures
pendant tout le temps où ça a duré
il criait il demandait que l'on tape mon
père encore plus il ya ma il disait même
qu'il fallait le fusil et sur place
oui alors là je comprends bien
avec qui il peut parler
federico aguirre madrid ont fait des
vicois guiré mais c'est mon copain on
était en classe ensemble tu le connais
bien sûr je le connais on a fait nos
études ensemble comment vous croyez que
je peux le voir
extraordinaire coïncidence surtout les
avocats qui travaillent ici je tombe sur
federico mon ami d'enfance
du coupé les cheveux
comment camarade vient bien ça fait si
longtemps
vous étiez bien des potes
royal
fait d'hélico lui aussi a vu disparaître
des membres de sa famille depuis il
consacre sa vie à pourchasser les
tortionnaires
comme je te disais nous sommes en train
de regrouper les informations pour
pouvoir faire pression sur les
politiques
ce qu'on veut c'est un délai
supplémentaire pour pouvoir rajouter
tous les cas qui n'ont pas été pris en
compte
comme le tiens par exemple tu sais il ya
encore quelques mois tout le monde
croyait y compris nous que cela ne
concernait pas les enfants
mais la triste réalité c'est que eux
aussi ont subi des violences en fait
comme moi quand ils ont arrêté mon père
non oui il ya même eu des enfants qui
ont été emprisonnés pendant des années
avec leurs parents
ils n'ont toujours pas été reconnue
comme victime alors qu'eux aussi ont
survécu à la prison et à la torture
quoi qu'ils étaient mineurs à l'époque
faut que tu as été maltraités par des
représentants de l'état
c'est pour cela et parce qu'ils ont
commis un crime contre l'humanité que tu
dois apporter plein classe installe
toi ta famille et tous ceux qui ont
survécu fait des vies comme mon ami
d'enfance accepte de s'occuper de mon
dossier première confrontation devant le
juge d'ici six mois
avant de rentrer à paris je décide
d'aller annoncer moi même la nouvelle à
l'homme qui a bouleversé ma vie mes
soeurs et mes nièces m'accompagne muni
d'une caméra pour que toute la famille
puisse enfin voir le visage de mario a
listé
bonjour est ce que je pouvais parler
avec mario s'il vous plaît oui d'où
venez vous d'ici là du quartier ok mais
pourquoi vous n'avez pas appelé avant
tu es français est à moitié moitié mais
je suis sûr que votre perle à se
rappeler de nous
ivan eibach il bahreïn ibars haiba
je nomme je suis désolé de vous dire que
c'est non il n'est pas disposé à vous
parler de quoi que ce soit ils me disent
qu'il n'a rien à dire il dit qu'il n'a
rien à dire alors qu'on puisse seulement
que je suis venu de france jusqu'ici
pour aider une histoire vieille de 30
ans
exactement de ce qu'il nous a fait à
chacun de nous les venus chez nous
escortés par des militaires et a vu mon
père se faire torturer devant mes yeux
et il n'a rien fait pour l'empêcher au
contraire vous savez ça aussi c'est
considéré comme la torture et c'est un
crime contre l'humanité je suis venu ici
pour le poursuivre en justice lui et
tous ceux qui étaient présents ce
soir-là
parvienne malgré qu'il soit mon père
mais il est amputé des deux jambes tu
comprends
amputé des deux jambes
tu pense qu'il faut le punir dieu s'en
est déjà chargé
non mais moi je veut punir personne je
veux seulement qu'ils répondent devant
la justice
atta plage en ferait autant que veux tu
que je te dise je sais pas moi alors
c'est que vous vous sentez comment
d'avoir un père comme ça
dieu m'a donné la force de la force dans
le coeur et le pardon
je te demande pardon en mon propre nom
bien que je ne me sens pas coupable
bon pour ça je te remercie mais en ce
qui concerne ton père tu saches que je
vais aller jusqu'au bout
c'est sans doute pour cela qu'il ne veut
pas te recevoir il en sait plus que moi
tu comprends oui je comprends mais lui
il faudra qu'il s'explique devant un
juge en tout cas quel courage un de sa
part il est courageux ton père
je sais qu'il n'est pas courageux
il n'a jamais été courageux
à bientôt à bientôt
il a des chances ce connard d'avoir une
fille comme ça
pas grave
mais c'est pas grave devant le juge il
sera seul nom sera là
cette visite mon père ne l'a jamais fait
mais je suis sûr qu'il aurait aimé la
manière dont elle s'est déroulée ce soir
là toute la famille s'est retrouvée un
nouveau soudés par la perspective du
procès à venir même ma mère d'habitude
si discrète a tenu à prendre la parole
je voudrais dire quelque chose ce soir
ça tombe très belle réunion parce que
cela fait de nombreuses années que l'on
ne s'est pas réunie mais je sais que ce
soir ils barbe est avec nous tous sa
santé
et comme souvent chili la soirée s'est
terminée dans les pleurs les rires et
les chansons
pour quelques heures à nouveau le temps
du bonheur comme à l'époque de mes 6 ans
avant le 13 septembre
[Musique]
manu collard
[Applaudissements]